hey guys it's dez de padatha here and
i'm david griffin your resident comic
book and video game goo here to talk to
you about some shield casting news amy
acker one of the many geek goddesses of
the world here is going to be playing
Coulson's girlfriend on Marvel's agents
of shield those of you who are weed
nights I am part we denied or seen
firefly love firefly she was an angel
has also been in the angel alias she's
done to all out all house and she did
for those of you watch the arrow review
she did a voiceover for hunters in the
Justice League animated series so
masking Dennis who is seen all these
shows angel doll house how is Amy Acker
he thinks will do a good job coming into
the Marvel Universe yeah I really like
ami Akron actually think she's a really
good actress she yeah she was in angel
which she played a winner fred and also
another character elyria which all the
girls love that character she's just
like this badass and she's also I don't
know yeah I don't want to spoil what
happens with her but and then she played
a whiskey in doll house and she was in
apparently the last season of alias
which I didn't see I think that was the
only season I didn't see of alias but
yeah she's a she's a weed in regular
right much like how summer glau has
appeared in a bunch of it joss whedon TV
shows and a few other people like
friends kranz but if you pronounce his
name alexis denisof right people like
that they weren't much to do about
nothing right yeah just off-screen Rick
did that so I I think it's a good
addition some people are saying oh well
it seems like it's just a one-off
episode I don't think so so we gotta
Coulson's girls coming on now you know
we finally get this story about the
cella so we've been waiting to hear from
and you know got the awesome i love that
conversation between Tony Stark and him
back in Avengers when he's talking about
you know I can fly to portland I'll see
this chalice will take care of it no
problem and nothing to see her like you
know the question is now is she just
going to be this one-off character how
far how long they'll carry her story for
I don't think she's gonna be a one-off
character I think she's not gonna be a
series regular
Amy ackers a series regular on persons
of interest now so I but I at the same
time I don't think they're just gonna be
one done with her I think maybe they'll
have her in this episode maybe we won't
see her again this season but I think
maybe we'll see her again next season
cuz why why cast Amy Acker if you're
just gonna do a one-off right and maybe
this alludes to plans for ABC looking in
the future maybe they still have hopes
for the series even though it has lost
its audience it still does get a
following I mean you know better than
some other show so maybe they're playing
the head to season two and trying to get
you know maybe they think they can grab
her for next season or something like
that or she could be like a recurring
guest character probably yeah probably i
think it's gonna be more likely i like
Margo Martindale for me like a big
family Americans bargain Margo
Martindale even though she's on that
comedy series that got picked up for a
full run I believe she pops it on the
Americans every down there so hopefully
we'll be able to see more of her hopes
he gets more like I'll give the show
cred I've been the show's biggest
supporter but you know SIF I felt even
though I liked that episode seen lady
SIF I didn't I felt like the reason as a
crutch at least this they're trying to
kind of like bring in even though she's
a character that's been mentioned in the
past she's not an established character
in the Marvel Universe per se so I like
that there's kind of you know creating
their own new characters yeah that was
all that was the whole thing as people
were speculating when they heard of this
jealous person who it could be alright
so apparently it's more of a new made
other Eric tur and who knows what this
superhero or super power threat from the
past is that emerges to that because
Agent Coulson hasn't revealed to her
they still lodged still thinks he's dead
so I'm sure in this episode there's
gonna be some you know slapping of the
face from from her to him but yeah so I
wonder if she herself has any type of
superpower yeah probably alright guys so
let us know what you think you can post
your comments below on the website from
care.com or on our youtube channel think
carroll pro make sure to subscribe to
that let's go check us out on twitter
find out or let us know what you think
of amy acker being cashew we'd nights
out there it's in general we think about
finally learning about the cellist and
who this mystery girl that Coulson's
been seen is and you can find this on
twitter at think hero i'm at griffin d
and we also have a Facebook page that's
fair
spocom / think hero fans make sure you
like that page and share our videos on
Twitter and other social media
you